saw in backstage in your opening
monologue that you you you mentioned
Dick Cheney this you know embittered
bacteria of some humanity who and I
think about it's always it's always a
surprise to me to remember that you know
through Bionic technology and so on this
this guy still here and and still not
given the credit and I wanted to give
him the credit since you mentioned him I
mean these are the guys he and President
Bush and some others who invented - or
Isis I mean they really are that was
created it so I wanted to give him a
shout-out thanks for that you want to
give credit where credit's due right but
then we've had people like Harvey Milk
who were beautiful brilliant impactful
guys and you know it's just no good deed
will go unpunished and then you got the
Chinese this is just me musing yeah
you're at the right place you know you
mentioned you we were talking backstage
I just wanted to mention it that we just
been you were asking me about Cuba cuz
we just did a show in Cuba and you said
that you I had no contact with anyone
the Cuban government but you've actually
spoken interviewed Raul Castro did you
ever meet Fidel Castro yeah you did yeah
so you've met both the Castro's and
what's your what's your feeling because
people now I heard talks today may have
may have halted temporarily but do you
think that this is something there's
gonna be real change in Cuba oh there's
certainly gonna be real change in Cuba
and with that and separate apart from
the Castro's I think that you know as
you saw the Cuban people have you know
in incredible spirit incredible
intelligence incredible and very bright
you know among the positive things that
the revolution brought were you know
literacy and so with access that will
increase you know being able to talk to
the world and so on I think it's going
to be very exciting change in what they
can bring to us culturally is going to
be very exciting so this are
k ik embargo which you know and really
was a blockade because for a ship to
come to the states it had to be six
months after it had gone to Cuba so
nothing could really go to Cuba because
it wasn't cost-efficient so it come here
so all of those things will change and
you'll have this magic population as
part of the bigger world and so ya know
I'm really looking forward to it and you
also obviously you do a ton of work in
in Haiti so I'm wondering like is that a
place that you know should I do my next
late-night show in Haiti yes would you
take me there absolutely you would yeah
and also that's one of the interesting
things that's going to come of Cuba
beginning to open up is that it's you
know that's just a puddle jump away from
port-au-prince and for the rest of Haiti
and I think that that'll be a you know a
great thing for Americans that are
travellers to be able to make that chime
in a port-au-prince is an hour and a
half from Miami Beach so this is all you
know right in our neighborhood right
you